it might shock you to hear this but um
donald trump is back to doing rallies he
was shot out of a cannon
yesterday rampant speculation that
donald trump
is still under the influence of steroids
because he did see manic and i have to
tell you
i have never seen donald trump speak
this quickly or act as
manically or maniacally choose which one
you like
as he did last night but we will get to
that because first i have to set the
context for you
donald trump who reportedly only first
tested negative for coronavirus since
having it
on the flight to sanford florida
did a mass rally yesterday in the state
of florida
which is you can see if you're watching
along with me
very few masks even on the stage behind
donald trump essentially
no masks among the crowd not on the
stage
right behind him they do not care much
the same way that trump's
rallies aren't politics they're more
like
sporting events trump's crowds are not
connected to the reality of a global
pandemic it is not just some of their
ideas
that are in the 1950s their
uh day-to-day is nine months
stale from when we didn't have a
pandemic usually at least
the people on the screen behind trump on
the stage who are
on screen behind trump are told you have
to wear masks
here more than half of the people even
on stage visible behind trump didn't
have masks on
and then before we get into some of the
specifics just a little bit about the
atmospherics
aside from the barely any masks
situation
and no social distancing whatsoever
florida republican governor ron desantis
was at the rally
without a mask high-fiving rally goers
touching everybody's hands we have video
of it that we've been showing our
audience as if once again
there's been no global pandemic raging
for the last eight months now you really
have to see it to believe it
so that's the context in which this
rally is happening
maskless republican governor high-fiving
people
no social distancing very few masks a
recently coveted positive president
delivering a speech now on to the speech
donald trump appeared completely manic
now the speculation of course is that
it's still the dexamethasone or or
simply
that trump was given a steroid so that
he would have more energy for the rally
he did seem tired towards the end
struggling more to project his voice and
breathe but he was out of control
trump again alluding to the consequences
of crimes that still have not yet been
enumerated
by obama biden and hillary bizarre
dystopian authoritarian moment take a
look change because we are doing more
for this country than any administration
has ever done despite the witch hunts
and the phony stuff that we caught them
on now we caught them cold and we'll see
what happens with that just watch
stay tuned so of course this is
completely
authoritarian strongman trump last week
said
that joe biden should be indicted uh and
trump still has not been able to tell us
what laws were broken by barack obama
by joe biden by hillary clinton the
crowd doesn't care
the crowd loves it trump then referred
to his campaign as a campon
in another one of these verbal glitches
and you'll see this one take shape
uh very quickly we achieved all of this
despite the fact
that we caught them cold they were
spying on our camp
it's our campaign it's our campaign not
my campaign trump did that thing there
where his brain
realizes that what's coming out of his
mouth doesn't make any sense
so he sort of just stops short and
restarts a different
sentence we've seen it happen at this
time at this point dozens and dozens of
times
trump then again with this entire
we're going to take care of them after
the election
horribly authoritarian and it actually
leads to chance of lock them up
again a sort of a staple of the trump
rally
calling for the jailing without due
process of
trump's political adversaries take a
look but we'll take care of it all after
the election
we caught him called we caught him
called bad people crooked hillary
and by the way obama and biden knew
everything that was happening okay just
in case you had any questions
we'll take care of it after the election
joe biden
and the democrat socialist but that
gives you another reason to go out
and vote we got to get in
because we don't they'll just sweep it
under the rug
you also hear in addition to lock them
up
trump again referring to biden as a
socialist
we had a good phone call about this last
week from someone saying
uh during live calls a young lady called
in and said listen my family believes
joe biden's a socialist when i try to
talk to them to them about the election
they say joe biden's a socialist he's
her family's cuban we're going to be
like cuba it's going to be a castro
again
and i don't know what to say when they
say that whenever someone says biden is
socialist
the first question must be which
socialist
policies are is biden advocating for
usually that will short-circuit like 95
percent you know 19 out of 20 of those
diatribes and they'll move on to
something else it because the answer is
obviously biden is not advocating for
any socialist policies
much to the chagrin of actual socialists
who want a further left democratic
presidential candidate but
doesn't matter facts don't matter all
that matters is feelings
at trump's rally trump then taking his
anger out on the media here he is saying
that the media are the sickest of them
all
these people are the sickest of them
[Applause]
you know uh turning an entire crowd
against reporters and camera people in
the back of the room
is is very strong man dictator-ish it
really is and i'm sure you all know that
and then this moment totally wild
trump saying he feels so good and again
this could be the steroids talking
dexamethasone and other steroids can
make you euphoric
trump saying he feels so damn good that
covid trump wants to go into the
audience
and kiss the men and the attractive
women take a look at this
but if you want to get out there get out
one thing with me the nice part
i went through it now they say i'm
immune i can feel i feel so powerful
i'll walk into that order
i'll walk in there i'll kiss everyone in
that audience
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
women and um
everybody i'll just give you a big fat
kiss
no but there is something nice i don't
have to be locked up in my basement and
i wouldn't allow that to happen anyway
so that's trump's manic upper voice
which we've come to recognize it's at a
12
since he's been on whatever medications
he's been on for coronavirus
trump continuing to mock joe biden by
the way
for having safe events trump ridiculing
biden
while he has he being trump has super
spreader events
you know these are the real polls so
when did you hear about this meeting
like a day ago
these are the real pulse right
the other guy gets out there and he's
they work and work and work and 30
people show up they put them in those
crazy circles right
they only have the circles because
that's the only way they can fill up the
room that's true
trump himself appears to have caught
coronavirus at an event
he organized at the white house for amy
coney barrett
and he's laughing at joe biden he
laughed at him during the debate for
wearing masks
he's now laughing at joe biden for
having small socially distant campaign
events
and the crowd just loves it the crowd is
cheering the guy who caught coronavirus
at one of his own events
for saying the other guy's events
aren't full of people during a pandemic
it's backwards everything that's
happening is completely backwards
and uh there was a i'm not going to play
the clip for you
for this this next clip but there was
another hilariously ignorant moment
during the rally where if you watched
behind trump there were people with
blacks for trump
shirts there were people with latinos
for trump shirts there were some puerto
rico
shirts puerto ricans for trump and trump
said at one point puerto rico better
vote for me
now of course puerto rico doesn't vote
in the presidential election because
it's
not a state i would love for puerto rico
to be a state
many on the left would love for puerto
rico to be a state trump
still confused about puerto rico even at
this late stage in the game
these rallies are going to continue this
week i'll be covering
both trump and biden events this week
also an update debate number two was
scheduled for thursday
when the commission on presidential
debates said we'll do it virtual because
trump has coveted
trump said no then the debate has been
canceled altogether the latest is that
joe biden will be doing a 90-minute town
hall
and that trump is pursuing a competing
town hall we don't know if it will be
back to back on different networks at
the same time on different networks
i don't know but i'm here we are here
through election day so i will be
covering
whatever it is that ultimately happens
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
an excellent
company shipping is just five bucks and
shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david